hi everyone I'm Jamil mala Dina from the
Google Play team glad you could all
stick around for the end we've got a
really fun session here for you
anchoring the end of the session to my
left is Mike Festa who is the director
of Wayfarer next and Tatsuo Nomura who
is the senior product manager on Pokemon
go from Niantic and you know that's that
kind of is the official titles but of
course you know there's so much more to
what you actually do I'm wondering if
you can give us a little bit of a
background about what you know how you
rode to get here and what it is that
you're actually doing
starting with yeah absolutely thank you
again for having us so I work at
Wayfarer we sell furniture online and I
created a team called Wayfarer next it's
essentially the R&D department
internally at Wayfarer and we were
looking at you know cutting-edge
technologies like you know tango and
daydream for AR and VR and I think it's
a great fit because we're selling
products online we don't have a store
you can't come in and like see the couch
and sit on it but this is I think one of
the next best things that we can offer
and so I started my team about a year
ago it was kind of coming off of a
successful hackathon using the Google
tango development kit and people
internally got excited about it and said
like let's you know make a team and make
this an important and endeavor for us
but taking a little bit further back in
time how did how did you get inspired
with AR what was it that was interesting
that got you on that track I shouldn't
been presented in the hackathon yeah so
I've always been interested in you know
AR and VR as long as I can remember
since being a kid and seeing you know
all these like promises of you know VR
you know virtual worlds and the matrix
is like a big inspiration for me and I
feel like you know I've been following
the technology for a long time I was you
know one of the early founders or
backers of oculus before they did a
Kickstarter and I've been playing with
you know these types of technologies so
when you know I saw the tango video and
actually signed up immediately
and I had a tango dev kit but I hadn't
had the opportunity to really you know
take the time out of my personal life
and we actually write an app or do
something interesting with it even
though I really wanted to and so then
the way for hackathon came up and I said
I know just the thing
do and that's you know use this AR
technology to kind of show how it can
apply to you know what we do and sell
furniture makes sense
Tatsuo how about you what's your story
so I I studied in Japan I went to grad
school in Japan and after graduated I
joined Google Japan and then I spent
about a year there as a software
engineer then I moved to u.s. to Google
headquarters in Mountain View and I
joined Google Mobile Maps team and then
after that I joined this internal
startup called Niantic labs which later
became Niantic that's how I got involved
now you had the good fortune to become
involved with a company that was already
working in AR Mike your situation is
probably more familiar to a lot of the
folks in the audience where you're
working with a company that has a has a
business on Google Play but you wanted
to bring AR to the product how did you I
mean so you had the successful hackathon
how did you go about working with your
management to to develop an AR product
yeah absolutely
so it can be a tough sell for you know
product that doesn't exist that may
never exist that's out there in this
kind of prototype form but I think what
really sold it internally was that the
key benefit or you know the
differentiator between this technology
and what we have currently was so
profound that it really enabled the
shopping experience at home to be better
than at the store so when you think
about you know I want to buy a new couch
you get to measure the space you get to
figure out how it's going to fit in your
home then you get to go to the store you
get to see the product imagine it in
your space and often times you go to a
furniture store and it's like huge
ceilings and you know you get the big
spaced out things and the giant couch
looks small until you get it in your
home and then you realize it's too big
so I thought that was a great use case
for us to say here's the exact product
in your space fitting exactly as it
needs to fit and I think then you know
the long-term vision for that is that
this technology is going to be in every
phone in the next you know five years
let's say and we want to be ahead of the
curve we want to start producing 3d
models and 3d content so that by the
time every
has the technology our entire catalog is
covered that makes sense I mean a lot of
people hesitate to buy furniture online
I actually did buy a couch on Wayfarer
but I can imagine a lot of people would
kind of stumble through that not being
able to place it in their home right and
it's only about 7% of furniture sales
that happen online today it's one of the
last like remaining like
brick-and-mortar you know businesses
that is still you know not like going to
online or we've seen you know the last
decade or even almost two decades of
more and more consumer goods going
online especially things that you don't
necessarily need to see or touch like if
you need to order batteries or paper
towels it's easy to just buy those on
Amazon because you know exactly what
you're getting
especially repeat purchases like that
with furniture it's a little different
it's very unique it's personal you care
about how it looks and I think one of
the interesting things that Wayfarer
offers is a huge selection so we have
over 7 million products and any you know
taste and style that you can think of we
have that product online versus the
traditional store where you go in and
what you see is what you get basically
there's a limited amount of space you
can put the product in yet it's only 7%
right now and I think part of the
barrier is that you want to see exactly
how it's going to look in your space and
then you want to be able to sit on and
touch it and that's another even more
future facing technology but I feel like
you know one win at a time and yeah they
are you know use case of like this is
how it's going to look is only going to
accelerate that shift online so opening
up that larger market was something that
you kind of identified now toss well one
of the things that you've been working
on eat so granted Niantic was already
into AR but working with Pokemon was
something that you already had an
experience with you know could you talk
a little bit about that right so as I
explained I was working for Google Maps
team before joining Niantic and every
year we will do this April Fool's
projects projects and he's more like a
joke thing I in 2012 we did this thing
called Google Maps 8-bit basically we
turned the whole map into the classic
video game Nintendo theme that was my
project and that
was that went pretty well and everybody
loved it since then people started to
ask me to do April Fool's and the
following year we did another one's
called Google Maps treasure treasure
mode so basically we turned the map now
this to a treasure treasure map looking
and we hit like monsters and you know
treasures for people to look for for and
then the following year that's when I
started working on Google Maps mobile
the Android Google Android Maps and we
were talking about what to do
rightful April Fool's yeah I came up
with this idea to you know what if I had
the Pokemon the maps I played a lot of
video games growing up of course you
know Pokemon Street Fighter Final
Fantasy all these games and every year I
was thinking the terms of gaming so that
year I came up with the idea doing
Pokemon and we did this on the Google
Maps and that got pretty we got
generated a quite big buzz and at the
same time there was this internal
startup called Niantic labs within
Google that John Honka was leading and
they Niantic had a product still has the
product called ingress which is a are
game where you go outside to play and he
contacted me after the April Fool's he I
think so he asked Todd so do you think
we can do something with Pokemon you
know Pokemon in the real world whether
that will make sense and of course right
like because I play the game when I was
little I watched all the anime old
movies right I basically was imagining
myself in fans have this fantasy that I
am the ash and going out to catch them
all so that immediately you know clicked
so I took John and two to go to Japan to
meet the Pokemon people there's a
company called the Pokemon company they
own the IP so we went there we we
introduced ingress and the concept of a
real world gaming and they are they're
very much loved the ideas well that's
how we started we decided to do
these together it started at the project
that's I mean the natural fit seems to
be a really common characteristic here
because the original Pokemon game has
you finding Pokemon in the world and
capturing them and and of course you
know placing furniture in your home is
what you naturally want to do it seems
that having that fit to what people want
to do was was a really kind of driving
factor as opposed to the technology for
the technology's sake yeah and I think
companies that want to embrace like a
are just for the flashier for the buzz
they might have some initial like
interest or success and I think that's
great and exciting to you know get out
there and experiment with it but at the
end of the day you have to make sure
you're answering a core business need as
well it's like how can this technology
make our offering better to the company
or you know how can we make our gameplay
more engaging or interesting and as long
as you're solving those problems then I
think you know you'll be successful in
the long run great so yeah I mean
totally so I think for Niantic our our
our mission is Adventures on food with
others so what we are really trying to
do is not necessarily this is a gimmicky
AR thing what we're trying to do is to
bring people to outside to explore to
exercise to communicate with other
people that's our core value and we
achieve that by using this AR that
happened to be you know the right timing
and right fit for the IP and everything
so it sounds like you're more about
enriching the lives of the people
playing and using the apps I mean that's
it's it's providing something the
technology is simply a tool but what
you're actually trying to do is enrich
their lives yeah absolutely yeah yeah
that point so you know since you're both
the product owners of your respective
app and game I'm wondering if you could
if we could have a little bit of a
discussion about what the design and and
production and development challenges
were so let's take design first
so was there was there something about
your hypothesis of the design of each of
your products that you found along the
way you know you needed to change or
that you learned in the process of
creating needed to be changed in term
design yeah absolutely so one of the
things we like to do now is open office
hours so the end of the week on Friday
is from 3:00 to 5:00 we invite people
throughout the company we have 3,000
employees in Boston to just come up and
play around and see what we're doing and
that's been great user testing because
we can get this like you know hands-on
test especially with tango where it's
something we can't just send out to
people's devices we actually have to see
them interact with them and give them
the device but getting outside of
engineering and getting people that are
you know working with products and
they're shopping at home and they're
organizing these categories getting them
to use the app was really rewarding and
interesting and I think we iterated a
lot on the UI and the design based on
you know those conversations and that
feedback and working with you know
people just giving them the device and
not saying anything saying go you know
use it seeing where the pitfalls were
what gestures worked like for example we
had a two finger rotation thing first so
you swipe left and right to rotate the
product no one could figure it out so we
realized like everyone's trying to
circle like do the circle rotate even
though it didn't necessarily match what
we were thinking and when we switched to
that we found that people naturally got
it a lot faster so like little things
like that I think the user testing goes
a long way right on yeah
Tatsu I guess for us one of the big
thing is when we started the project we
thought we can just stop have the
pokemons running around you know on the
map yeah
tried it obviously didn't work because
we have I have to as a player running
around chasing pokemons just doesn't
work in the real world that's something
we finally found out but in terms of
design we because it's a game we expect
people to play in the outside we really
tried hard to make the whole old
gestures or UI reachable from your thumb
that's why the Pokemon game you've
opened it most of the major tasks you
can accomplish by just one finger that's
something we've tried really hard and
with that we like there's one unique
gesture in our game where you can use
one finger to rotate the map like even
internally we had some debate some
people were thinking that is not
sounding something people used to maybe
we should not do it but after
implemented and tested with various
people everybody liked it so and we
decided to do that so there are a lot of
like what you said you know trial and
error about during the process but in
your case though it seemed like there
was quite a bit more involved with the
throw mechanic so I mean people of all
ages kids my parents I mean everyone
seems to naturally get that and get a
lot of thrill out of that but it wasn't
a very simple thing right right yeah
yeah that was that part actually was
pretty hard even if you think it is just
you know flicking your finger how hard
that is but uh it took I think we did
three or four iterations just to get it
right because you know on the phone
they're different people have different
phone size and have different resolution
so to make it work full across the
devices that was very challenging is I
think we can still improve it but uh
like one of the thing we really Oh was
difficult is the the rate of the
sampling we're using a unity in our app
the unity sample samplers
you know kit has some room for
improvement so we we we we had to work
you know work around it to make sure
that when you flick it goes it's a 2d
map into 3d so make it sure that you
feel like you are doing it right so okay
now you're working with tango for the
first time AR is still a relatively new
technology did you encounter any impact
to your production schedule or to your
budget in in kind of working through
some of the kinks of AR I don't know
that we had I mean our team's a little
bit unique in the sense that were like a
dedicated R&D team so it's kind of
expected that we're gonna be hacking
things together and working with teams
like Google for example was working
closely with us to identify issues for
like the tango core and things that the
device was doing at a lower level and so
that was I think for us going into it
kind of expected we weren't looking for
this perfect out-of-the-box solution it
was more like okay we're going to be
investing our D to cutting-edge tech so
you know one of the things that comes
with that is this kind of unknown around
like development time where you know in
general as an engineer like I find a lot
of times it's really hard to estimate
how long a particular task is going to
take because you might come to a quick
conclusion or something might just work
and that's awesome but a lot of times it
doesn't and then you have to kind of
like investigate and pick and poke and
figure out why something that isn't
working isn't working and then
eventually get to your solution that's
you know it's great to be an engineer
it's fun to get that Eureka moment but
there's a lot of time where there's that
kind of unknown window of is this gonna
work is you know am i doing the right
thing is is this our code is this
Google's code is this a device problem
and I think a lot of that stuff has been
ironed out at this point which is great
but over the last you know with say
eight months or so while we were doing
the core development it was one of those
things that you know we just kind of
kept it like trial and error
see what works and try to make changes
and improvements and now it's like super
solid so it's been it's been great what
would you recommend to people developing
AR with tango what would you suggest
that they plan for yeah core development
Windom I mean I think the first thing to
do is to actually just get a device in
your hands in your office and start
showing people some of the existing apps
that are out there
then with that device heavier developers
you know we use unity I think a lot of
companies do these guys using unity as
well try the unity toolkit because
Google provides like a great starting
point in unity where you can basically
plug in your device load up the sample
apps makes them make some changes so for
my hackathon that's essentially what I
did I use the Google AR code and I
actually spent more time on my hat on
just drawing and modeling the product so
that they looked good then actually
worrying about the room mapping and the
AR portion of it unity just gives you a
camera that follows the device as you
move it around so I think you know
that's the great way to get into it just
experiment with it and if you feel like
there's a match for the technology then
think about okay what what's the core
product that we're going to develop and
it's not that unlike developing for
Android or developing for gaming in
terms of the technology because Google
handles most of the underlying learning
portion of it for you
right on Tatsuo what about you I mean
whether any stumbling blocks let's see
so because we started as a non tech is
always focusing on AR so it's not like a
bringing in AR will affect us we started
as an AR so but I can talk about a
little more about the specifics like for
example the camera overlay you have the
pikachu standing in front of the camera
and react to your gyro that is actually
not that hard right it's pretty
rudimentary so you just put your object
there of course we have to you know do
do some tuning to make sure it looks
good and works you know depending on
what size of the pokemon looks correct
and everything but that part wasn't very
hard but the major part component of
another major component of the pokemon
go is the dis pokey stops and gems
those are real world locations like
probably this one this there there are a
lot of pokey stops in around this area
as well we collected all these data for
the past like three four years when we
did
we're with ingress so ingress users will
submit this what we call portal data
we had a when we started Pokemon go we
already had like multi million locations
that's something I think we took long
time to build up but once we have it
that's data using a foundation we had to
in order to build Pokemon Pokemon goal I
think that brings up an interesting
point and that's around the content and
so the development of the app is one
thing but the development of the content
you know can I also make or break your
business model or your plan and that's
one of the things we found at Wayfarer
we sell seven million products as I
mentioned and we started this without
having really any 3d models like from a
hackathon I was drawing stuff in the
office and one of the reasons that my
team was able to get created was because
internally we discovered that for our
photo studio were basically taking in
products setting them up nicely taking a
picture and that whole process was
relatively slow and expensive internally
one of our co-founders was working on a
new project to basically make 3d models
of the products for use in 3d renderings
so they came up with this business use
case that oh we can you know for a
fraction of the cost
render out a product and then have that
3d product for use in the future for
whatever other environment we want to
pull it into for these photorealistic
catalog shoots so because they were
creating the 3d content for that it
enabled my team to basically say well we
have 3d models now we can do AR but
without 3d contents in our case we
wouldn't have really had anything and so
making the app is one thing but
supporting with content is the you know
in some cases the larger challenge was
that an internally developed 3d modeler
so what we did is ended up we're using
various like outsourcing opportunities
and now we're partnering with different
companies that specialize in 3d content
production great and so on average it
cost about 25 dollars for us to model a
3d product and it's is cost savings over
the photography but my team is also
developing a 3d scanning technology that
I think will further drive down costs
and ultimately push that technology into
the hands of our suppliers and vendors
right that have the products in their
you know facilities then they can do
that
for us I think ultimately when we think
of an AR and VR a lot of its going to be
about the content and people start need
to think about you know the 3d aspect of
the content it's like a lot of ways is
like you know the web in their early
days when you want to start selling
stuff online you know it's like oh what
do I need to sell a product on the
Internet I need a picture I need some
descriptions and pricing sure and I
think if we want to sell stuff in a are
we need a 3d model and that's something
that in some cases it exists because
it's drawn and CAD but in other use
cases it doesn't in ours for most of our
products they don't exist in 3d so
that's an additional challenge that
we've been trying to address and I think
over the next few years we'll see the
technology get there so that almost
every product is going to have a 3d
representation but in order to you know
think about your application and what
content you're going to need yeah work
and it sounds like unity was helpful to
you as well in that process
Tatsuo I'm wondering were there any
third-party tools or or outsourcing
resources or anything else happening
around you guys that was helpful to you
that you know you basically relied on in
some capacity yeah
so like the 3d models right like we had
this 3d model from a Pokemon company
because I already created these 700 more
creatures sure we have that already and
in terms of tools we use unity as I
described before and will on the client
side we also developed our own plugin to
render the render the map and on top of
that on the background on the backend
our servers use Google Cloud moving
cloud engine excuse me yeah and that
definitely enabled us to you know scale
the game to the to the scale we have
today and Google team has been really
really supportive to us so yeah
that's being a I would be grateful as if
we so actually let's jump to that moment
so Tatsuo your game
comes out on a Friday in in without
featuring without anything walk us
through what happened that day in your
office let's see we we launched the
gaming no New Zealand and audio first
yes yes also we you know we didn't do
any advertisement because we were
worried that we'll get too much traffic
we wanted to expand it slowly to make
sure our servers don't meltdown so we
started in New Zealand Australia when we
you know when you push the button on
Google Play it takes it takes a couple
minutes or I actually longer like an
hour to propagate and for people to find
out we take a little longer so when we
just click along the botton and we
started monitoring the graph and like
nothing happens
oh wow and we were like yeah or people
you know we were we became a little bit
nervous watching the graph but after a
couple hours we started to see the graph
just going up and up and up this it
doesn't stop just keep going up and next
next morning we came to the office and
our engineering manager I'm the product
manager or engineering manager announced
so if we keep this rate we're gonna have
like anyway a crazy number of users and
we were still because we the the
previous day we were still looking at
the graph didn't you know move much and
we were a little skeptical or like now
we're now going to get that many users
but during the day the graph just keeps
going off and we started seeing online
like people started to do this event
among themselves like user organized
event in Sydney we saw like 3000 people
just gathered just started you know
walking crawling the city to catch
pokemon and that's when I think we found
out this is going a little crazy you
know what we expected and that's the day
actually the following day of the New
Zealand Australia launch we launched in
US and after we launched it I went back
home from from the office and oh that
was I think right after we clicked the
button
I just went back home after monitoring
for like 20 minutes and I bumped into
this person was holding the phone way
I'm doing this
and you medially I knew she was playing
poking pleasure and I was so happy I
couldn't stop myself
you know I just walked into her ass I
heard you playing Pokemon go and I think
I was probably look really creepy
because I was smiles on my face and
asking about her how do you like it and
how do you find it and everything and a
few days later we sell the Pokemon crawl
happened in San Francisco as well
they were like about 5,000 people
gathered in the market right walking
from from what was a very building I
joined them as a user and I see everyone
was like cheering and you know a lot of
people cause had cosplay Pokemon and the
teams that was really really a happy
moment of mine yeah that was it was
extraordinary we were talking about this
backstage about we remember where we
were when Pokemon exploded and certainly
you know in in terms of our relationship
we were a Maria Essig and I were
noticing that everyone around us was
playing and we go out on the street
everyone is playing it so that speaks to
a very specific metric that is important
to Niantic so conventionally we're
always talking about installs and
revenue but there's also something else
that is as important if not more
important that you guys are tracking
right yeah absolutely
oh I mean for in terms of downloads the
traditional traditional stats we we are
like I think in in September we had like
500 million downloads there's a great
number but there's a very you know
unique number to us up to I think
September we have the people walked
total 4.6 billion kilometers I don't
know how many miles is that I but is
that's like from here to Pluto that is a
crazy number so that number is very very
unique and thing and I think important
to us because what we're trying to do is
really our core value is to take people
to outside exercise communicate and be
healthier right that's what we are
trying to really do you know the game is
just a form of you know expression if
you will so and we also so so keep you
know articles and hearing from other
people like we see people in a hospital
Pokemon go using hospital to help kids
doing physical therapies are and we also
see examples of kids suffering from
autism were able to use Pokemon go to
communicate with even strangers and that
there is really this job I feel very
happy that I can you know involved in
someone's can have some impact to
someone's life in a positive way
and recently I think it was a Stanford
and Microsoft they published a study
saying that Pokemon go users are we
extended Pokemon go players life
expectancy by like 40 43 days Wow guys
so all those numbers I think are very
important to us down down the
traditional stats it's yeah it sounds
like it has more to do with caring for
the people playing your game than
actually tracking conventional metrics
and you know in a funny way there's also
maps to what we were talking about a
little bit it's not so much
about the installs for you either at
least at an initial level how are you
guys measuring impact and says yeah yeah
so certainly we have like the long-term
view that this technology is going to be
there eventually and we want to start
building our 3d product catalog now and
the devices are just available now so
I've like one of the Lenovo devices here
so you can buy them now and it'll be
interesting to see what the adoption
rate is like for that particular device
but no one's like expecting any ROI on
on what we've done so far it's like oh
this is an interesting experiment and in
a long term we see the value in the
short term it's been a lot more about
publicity for the company and just
showing that we're forward-thinking tech
company often times you know you think
of wafer you think of furniture you
think of you know the shopping
experience but at our core we consider
ourselves a tech company that happens to
sell furniture and so I think by doing
this type of initiative it's a great way
for you know not only recruiting but
also community awareness that oh wafers
like a you know a tech anchor in Boston
and these guys are doing some really
interesting stuff and then they learn
about what we're doing with them there's
so many other interesting things
internally that are going on like in our
data analytics and other you know teams
that are building all kinds of crazy
products and this is kind of like a way
to get people's attention and then you
know show a lot of publicity for the
company sounds great so gonna take a
slightly different tack now so both of
your products are out let's pretend I'm
Q you're Picard you are I have the
ability to redo your mission let's go
back to the beginning of your mission
what would you do differently now based
on what you know having shipped your
product hmm yeah so for me personally
it's good goes back to that kind of Mike
product model category and now that we
get the device out there we have 10,000
products digitized things products it's
like oh I wish we had you know 3d
scanned all of them for example like
we're hand modeling the products and
that weaves you know a certain sense of
artistic design let's say because
basically the 3d modelers looking at
photo references and they're not
necessarily looking at you know the real
product they're just looking at photos
of that product whereas the 3d scanning
technology
you were developing is like you know
millimeter accurate and we looks
photorealistic and the actual great
representation of the product so I'm
really excited about the future for that
but I wish we could have done that from
the beginning rather than had this
interment intermediary step of hand
modeling all the products but the
scanning technology is something that's
you know it's constantly being developed
Google had an internal scanning company
as well that I guess got the axe
unfortunately but it's one of those
technologies that's like really
promising for the right product and then
really challenging for the wrong product
like this end table wooden scan well
because it's all white and when you try
to reconstruct it
there's no good references to to get it
looking good so we're working on
techniques to kind of enhance the
scanning process but I wish we could
have had that like what we have today a
year ago and what we're going to have in
a year two years ago you know basically
that Ottoman with the geometric print
really presented well yeah showing me
yeah so that was a nice aw that was
again it was a hand model actually so is
an artist that kind of put together what
it looked like based on photos and you
know not to discredit the modelers they
do a great job of making the products
look amazing but I I feel like you know
one of the big things we're trying to
push is that super accurate this thing
is exactly how it fits in your space and
I think you lose some of the detail in
the precision by doing the hand modeling
approach versus the 3d scanning approach
so it's one of those things that we
still don't have a perfect solution for
but I wish if I could go back in time we
had what we have now or even better to
use that to build our 3d models from the
beginning from 3d scan data fair enough
Tatsuo so you if you work you I'll
probably ask you to just give me a real
Pikachu the only thing you do is at the
time I guess what we would have done is
so we probably would have increased our
server capacity to begin with
all right to to the you know scale where
what we have today that's one thing we
would do but in terms of other things I
think we we bear we just launched the
game like just a few months ago we still
planned a lot of things that we haven't
even done or you know haven't even get
to yet so even I don't think there's a
different things I would do differently
except the server potion yeah you're
kind of beginning your adventure now
aren't you yeah yeah so last question I
want to kind of take our official hats
off you know looking at it from the
point of view of being pioneers in AR
where do you Tatsuo and Mike think AR is
going or where should it go or what are
the forces that need to change in order
to bring about an AR future that you see
is rewarding in like five years or so
alright yeah I'll start so this is
something I've been thinking about like
most of my life and Google's been doing
a lot of interesting innovation in the
space of mapping the world when you
would go what's going on with like
Google Earth for example I think with AR
technology we can bring that to
interactive street-level technology
essentially so when we're scanning a
space we can present that space in
what's a virtual reality for example and
we can have this interaction in using AR
with people that are in the same space
but in VR so they could teleport there
and be there with us we can walk around
the street together and you know look at
different things or pull in different
objects so I think this idea of
augmenting the world and creating a data
set a rich data set that lives on top of
the real space that we're in will enable
us to connect better with people both in
the real sense we were both together
looking at a thing or landmark but also
with a third person that could be
somewhere else in be are experiencing
with us
so I'm excited for you know that type of
technology that's coming from the
culmination of 3d scanning automatic
reality and virtual reality and you know
big data to be able to serve all of this
data so that we can actually get to that
point that sounds awesome
so yeah I think like the technology is
just emerging right now the tango is
coming out in next year's I guess we'll
there will be new devices coming out but
even going a lot further eventually or
and hopefully I think you know the
device will become so small that you
don't know you for someone is wearing it
and you'll be able to basically you
won't be able to know whether this
Pikachu is real or that it Q you know
missing with you so and I guess everyone
like around my age or there are a lot of
game developers here today I think
imagined or had you know have this
fantasy that become hero or you know do
things that you won't be able to do in
real life but with the AR technology you
can become something right that you are
it could be a pokemon trainer it could
be I'm not a big fan of a fast
first-person shooter but if you want it
you can do that kind of gameplay as well
so I think there are a lot of
interesting thing we can do in terms of
an entertainment gaming but besides that
like what I'd like to wear my official
hat a little bit but so like what
Niantic trying to do is really to how we
thinking about how we can improve
people's you know life so not only doing
these tricks but like using the AR how
we can actually augment people's you
know life's realities if you will so
that's the area I think that that part
will evolve a lot as well like you can
now like if you can have I have have
this AR thing like what we do more
advanced version of what we do today the
local the real world is actually very
interesting in your neighborhood what we
try to do - for you to discover these
things little things like landmark in
your neighborhood you never never
visited or like a restaurant in a corner
that nobody knows like with a our
technology you can guide people to those
places so
they can that will actually enhance the
augmented reality I think that's where
the AR technology should be or will be
going to that's a beautiful vision I
think that's part of what everyone in
the EO AOR has this opportunity to do is
to bring people together in the real
world I think that's probably the best
note for us to end on thank you both for
joining us and here
[Applause]